he moves his king there offering  offering the  offering saints black queen if you want  to because  it's a mate no if you go there night oh  no  did he miss that maybe maybe he hasn't  got auto promote on  maybe he hasn't got auto this could be  this could be one of the weirdest  moments  ever but he has one no he didn't do it  he couldn't call him  it was a mate it was a mate he could  have gone d1 mate but he maybe  doesn't have auto promote on d1 equals  knight  is checkmate but maybe on his settings  he's put ultra  auto promote to a queen on i've never  seen that  i'm going crazy i mean look is that mate  what are we missing if he goes pawn to  d1  equals knight checkmate and he only has  how do i change it tonight where do i go  where is the knight i've got it on queen  oh no he's gone queen oh and now he  might get mated  now he might get mated what is going on